human nature the australian singing
sensation were headliners on the strip
for over a decade and now the boys are
back with a new residency at the south
point let's welcome back to the show we
got andrew michael and toby good to see
you guys
you guys are looking sharp are we
feeling feeling good we uh you did ask
us did we plan yes but when there's a
group you're kind of going to make a
phone call and say what are we going to
wear
so we thought about it and uh yeah we
dialed it in and also too if you lined
up it's like matching it will be lined
up with your photos behind you we're
always much more serious in photos you
were saying there's a dust storm out
there there's a madness out there
there's a blanket dust everywhere is
that what it's like in australia is it
dusty in australia when you go through
the middle of australia you get to be
dusty yeah this is this is unique out
there it's like armageddon gotta be
careful out there today absolutely
absolutely now what can we expect at the
at the new show at the south point and
we're excited i mean we've as you as you
said in the beginning it's been two
years since you know the pandemic kind
of shut everything down
so yeah we're excited to be starting
back up at the showroom at southpointe
um it's just gonna be great you know the
great songs of motown you know a real
energetic show and just yeah we're
excited to be getting back on stage and
doing what we love how was it during the
pandemic when you were where were you
guys during the pandemic did you still
perform via zoom how did you stay busy
we were here mostly but
thankfully we were actually able to go
back to australia last year we spent
about four months touring out there uh
but then we got locked they had
lockdowns yes
we had to cancel part of that we're just
about to go back to finish that off but
then yeah return from there to come and
start up at south point but um we're
excited we did some holiday shows at
south point and they were great the
room's really fantastic the room at
south point is amazing acoustics there's
not a bad seat in the house inside that
place i was surprised like it's probably
one of the best showrooms in the in the
strip you know it's like it's the
technology the seats like as you say if
you go and sit there you won't have a
bad seat it's kind of got that old
school loose yeah which we love if you
go you get a booth sit there have a
couple cocktails watch human nature
thanksgiving is two dollar drinks or
something is it really yeah
hey can you teach us real quick some
australian slang
give me give me something something
something you know want to feel the vibe
oh like it's truth yeah they know what
that is that's a beer right no i don't
want to drink a shrimp no no okay that's
a vb but we send all of eb out of
australia that's why it's famous
someone said to be wagging school like
when you skip school wagging school
wagging it's called you call it wagging
so i said what do you do when you're
wagging school so you skip school like
the trunk of the car yeah is the boot
it's like put it in the boot i i don't
want am i is it uh
you should you should take a sickie and
go see human nature in august oh yeah
absolutely
you actually say take a sickie and go
see the night because
the night
is a sick day we'll have you perform in
a second but
julie and i were talking about this
earlier real quick what was your first
concert in last concert first concert i
ever went to was actually the commodores
and the four tops i was really young and
they were um they came to australia so i
saw them in in in the entertainment
center of australia nice the first one
was i think i saw prince did you really
yeah yeah pretty good one it was a hard
one to beat i tell you wow because
brothers right
[Laughter]
all right you guys you get yes ready to
perform oh yeah we're always ready to
perform we're gonna sing i mean it's
always it's different to the show we're
live but we'll do a taste of something i
heard you guys warming up so i'm excited
to hear you doing here you can check out
human nature
back to the sound of motown residency
starting at the south point casino in
august visit their website for dates and
tickets take it away boys
[Applause]
in a river wide enough to keep me from
getting to you babe you know that there
ain't no mountain high enough
[Applause]
to keep me from getting to you babe